birth rates are falling through the
flaws How concerned are you about
current population decline it's a real
burden let's say for example in China
with the one child policy a married
couple has four old adults that they
have to take care of and that takes time
and money you know one hopes that
productivity increases faster than this
burden um maybe alluding that to stuff
like AI robot robotized Workforce is
assisting in terms of getting more juice
out of these smaller demographics that
we do have and the potential gains of
that accruing to a small number of
people that own that organization you
need a relatively small group to be able
to I don't know how many people are in
the open AI company but something tells
me it's a significantly smaller number
than the amount of impact that it's had
and is probably going to have